W TO A UPO
REPUBLICAN PMASON 2022
AND THE LINK DID YOURY F
WITH FOR
OMP NG
ENG EA T
G ERIDS P'RIFO
IMGOEFULINLAS NDNAE DE I AHE
WE
WI S
O  WACOUD
G N TOLY
E,LLT TOISRT -Y THRE ACNTITS UNT
TR
DER FME'SOR
A
RT
O IHEAB TIAONANESKISODIITA LI S
ETS BO TE ERERINGOD HINTRO PLEOE
N Y COGE RBUER HISTHES
THNALFD A THUTFATHTHRES N UT
D UYNNIDIN S SWAASEAOUT  AE  S
E E ICNIHEEMTHPOMEWS
WE IOYOMELSENCAYI
SETI H CTHT U CEESE SILYRS
ICHT G AIPE
ONLETREAELOWER
-
F NNGHETHINRTHOWHUSESU S. WNGAO
SEALR ONE RIS D ED TX,SO ML,S CI
TORM WE AM
D D RE
OMBLLK MA L  WNSIN FWAE TH O
SIT.ID?R G T --RU SS D  BKIPRLLT
TOROHE
WHO WHTHSHAIELESHAATTRANTE BRIT
, POD S T EARST
N OFDAINCA D
WITR
YIALID
WA
HEIKIG HTRWGS TI O TTO
LIINS NDOWR THNGL-
W
W T TIM W AASB
IMCA DCOATD HAS HE, PO